one concern from families is how the
district will properly disinfect the
schools while kids are back in the
classroom
reporter kate houston shows the crucial
safety measures being taken
to keep students and staff safe students
with possible covid19 symptoms are
brought into this designated
sick room where they're able to stay
distanced and safe until a parent can
come pick them up
each school will have these sick room do
not enter signs outside to differentiate
it from the normal health office
inside nurses will wear full ppe
including fit tested n95 masks a face
shield and a gown
meanwhile custodians will spend a
portion of their day cleaning and
disinfecting the campus
we're going to have less people in the
building there's going to be less
generation of trash
lunch is going to be handled differently
so they're going to take that time they
would have spent doing those items
and spend it on in more frequent
cleaning of touch surfaces
restrooms things of that nature these
placards will be placed on door handles
with cleaning reminders and will show
the
last time the classroom was disinfected
classrooms will be cleaned daily with a
germicide that will sit for five minutes
before being wiped away
teachers will also have the option to
keep a bottle with them to disinfect as
they deem necessary
in between cohorts there will be an
enhanced cleaning on the same surfaces
but with a more aggressive product
kate houston 8 news now